>> Jon: WELCOME TO THE DAILY
SHOW, MY NAME IS JON STEWART.
WE'RE BACK! BOOM! TONIGHT'S
GUEST, OLD FRIEND OF THE SHOW.
JUDGE ANDREW NAPOLITANO.
HE'S GOT HIS BOOK OUT,
"SUICIDE PACT."
WHICH IS, IT'S REALLY FUNNIER
THAN IT SOUNDS.
BUT FIRST, WHILE WE WERE ALL
HOME LAST WEEK, RIDDING THE
NATION OF ITS TURKEY
SCOURGE--
(LAUGHTER)
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY DID.
THE GRAND JURY VERDICT IN
MISSOURI WAS DECIDING THAT
FERGUSON POLICE OFFICER NOW
FORMER FERGUSON POLICE
OFFICER DARREN WILSON DID
NOTHING INDICTABLE WHEN HE
SHOT UNARMED BUT LARGE
MICHAEL BROWN.
THE ANGRY REACTION TO THIS
DECISION WAS SWIFT AND
SUSTAINED.
THE PROTESTS BREAKING OUT
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
BUT IF THOSE WHO TOOK THE
STREETS THOUGHT THAT THEY WERE
SPEAKING OUT AGAINST
SYSTEMIC INJUSTICE,
THEY COULD NOT HAVE BEEN MORE
WRONG.
>> THIS IS NOT A CIVIL
RIGHTS ISSUE.
>> IT'S NOT A BLACK WHITE
SITUATION.
>> IT'S A THUG-POLICE
OFFICER SITUATION.
>> PEOPLE FORGET, HE HAD
COMMITTED A ROBBERY.
>> MICHAEL BROWN WAS THE BAD
GUY IN THIS CASE.
AND PLEASE, AMERICA, LET'S
NOT TURN THIS KID INTO SOME
KIND OF CIVIL RIGHTS MARTYR
BECAUSE THAT HE IS NOT.
>> FERGUSON, MISSOURI IS NOT
SELMA, ALABAMA.
>> Jon: RIGHT!
(LAUGHTER)
ALMOST BY DEFINITION.
FERGUSON, MISSOURI, IS NOT
SELMA, ALABAMA.
OF COURSE, IF FOX HAD BEEN
AROUND FOR SELMA, ALABAMA,
THE HEADLINE WOULD PROBABLY
HAVE BEEN, RELAX, SELMA
ISN'T SLAVERY. SO THIS ISN'T A
CIVIL RIGHTS THING.
ALTHOUGH I DON'T KNOW.
THE PROTESTS I SAW SEEMED
PRETTY CIVIL RIGHTS-Y.
FROM THOSE IN LOS ANGELES TO
THE NFL, TO THE STREETS
RIGHT HERE IN NEW YORK.
>> [BLEEP] THE ANGER. [BLEEP]
THE LEVEL OF [BLEEP] [BLEEP]
VOICES [BLEEP] HAS ONLY
GOTTEN LOUDER.
AND THEY'VE PICKED PEOPLE UP
ALONG THE WAY.
>> [BLEEP] CNN [BLEEP] CNN!
AS YOU CAN HEAR [BLEEP] THESE
PEOPLE ARE WILLING TO PROTEST.
>> [BLEEP] CNN!
>> I FEEL YOU.
(LAUGHTER)
BUT I GET WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING THERE.
THIS IS AN ISOLATED
INCIDENT.
LIKE THE POLICE SHOOTING OF
TAMIR RICE IN CLEVELAND OR
DANTE PARKER IN SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY OR KENDREC
McDADE IN PASADENA OR ARMAND
BENNETT IN NEW ORLEANS OR
JOHN CRAWFORD -- WHAT TIME DOES
COLBERT START? WHAT TIME DOES
HIS SHOW START?
IT'S IN LIKE A HALF HOUR, RIGHT?
ALL RIGHT, WE'LL
JUST-- WE'LL MOVE ON.
THE POINT IS-- THESE
SHOOTINGS ARE CLEARLY NOT A
MANIFESTATION OF SYSTEMIC
INEQUALITY AND MISTRUST
BETWEEN THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN
COMMUNITY AND THE SOMEHOW
ALWAYS JUSTIFIED POLICE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
BUT THESE ARE MERELY AN
UNENDING BIZARRELY SIMILAR
SERIES OF ISOLATED
INCIDENTS.
(LAUGHTER)
BUT IF THERE IS NOTHING TO
JUSTIFY THE ANGER AND
PROTESTS IN THESE
COMMUNITIES, WHY WOULD SO
MANY INDIVIDUALS AROUND THE
COUNTRY SPEND THEIR PRECIOUS,
HARD-EARNED PRE-CHRISTMAS
SALE STAMPEDING TIME
PROTESTING A NONEXISTENT
PROBLEM.
>> YOU LOOK AT FERGUSON,
THEY HAD A COMMUNITY THAT
REALLY WORKED, OR IT SEEMED
TO HAVE WORKED.
AND NOW ALL THIS HATRED
IS COMING OUT.
YOU HAVE SO MANY OTHER
PEOPLE INCITING AND TRYING
TO GET THEIR OWN TWO CENTS
IN AND THEY'RE TRYING TO INCITE
PROBLEMS.
>> SURE.
>> PITTING WHITES AGAINST
BLACKS.
>> I THINK THE RACIAL
ARSONISTS IN THIS COUNTRY
HAVE WORKED THESE PEOPLE UP
SO MUCH WITH PROPAGANDA,
THAT FACTS DON'T MATTER.
>> OH, THAT'S WHY.
THEY TAKE TO THE STREETS.
THEY WERE INCITED BY RACIAL
ARSONISTS.
YOU KNOW, I HAVE A DREAM.
THAT ONE DAY WE CAN EVOLVE
AS A PEOPLE TO A TIME WHEN
ARSONISTS NO LONGER SEE RACE.
(LAUGHTER)
BUT SEE REALLY ONLY THE
BEAUTIFUL CONSUMING FIRE
THEY ARE CRIMINALLY COMPELLED
TO LIGHT. WHEN AN ARSONIST
CAN SAY THE ONLY COLOR I SEE
IS ORANGE.
BUT I GET IT, THEY'RE
OBVIOUSLY WOULDN'T BE A
PROBLEM IF A RACIAL
ARSONIST-- IF A RACIAL
ARSONIST HADN'T-- IF A
RACIAL ARSONIST HADN'T LIT
THE FIRE UNDER FERGUSON WITH
HIS TELLING OF WHAT HAPPENED
MATCH.
AND BY THE WAY, RACIAL
ARSONISTS WERE NOT THE ONLY
INCITERS.
>> THESE RACIAL
RACKETEERS.
>> RACE HUSTLERS
>> RACE GRIEVANCE INDUSTRY
LEADERS.
>> YOUR RACE GRIFTERS, YOUR
RACE COUNTERFEITERS, YOUR
RACE LITTERERS, YOUR RACE
FINANCIAL ADVISORS, YOUR
RACE, YOUR RACE SOMMELIERS.
WHAT IS WRONG WITH A NICE
WHITE?
BUT--
(APPLAUSE)
BUT THE POINT IS, THESE
PROTESTS MAY LOOK LIKE A
SPONTANEOUS GROUNDSWELL OF
FRUSTRATION, GRIEF AND ANGER
AMONGST THE COMMUNITY THAT
FEELS DISENFRANCHISED.
BUT THEY'RE ACTUALLY JUST
THE PRESCRIBED BIDDING OF
AMERICA'S RACE GRIEVANCE
PUPPETEERS.
AND WHO MIGHT THEY BE,
YOU ASK?
PROFESSOR?
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
>> THE PRESIDENT AND ERIC
HOLDER AND AL SHARPTON, I
THINK THEY'VE BEEN TERRIBLY
IRRESPONSIBLE.
>> FERGUSON BURNS BECAUSE OF
IN PART A MIND-SET WAS
CREATED BY AL SHARPTON, BY
ERIC HOLDER AND THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Jon: BE HONEST MY FRIEND,
ARE THOSE THE THREE PEOPLE
RESPONSIBLE OR DID YOU JUST
NAME THE ONLY THREE BLACK
GUYS YOU COULD THINK OF?
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
WHAT? WHICH ONE? FERGUSON BURNS,
MY FRIEND, IN PART BECAUSE OF
JAY-Z THE GUY WHO PLAYS URKEL
AND LET'S SAY HANK AARON.
I DON'T KNOW.
NOW HERE'S WHERE IT GETS
INTERESTING.
WHAT IS THE MIND-SET THAT
HAS BEEN INSTILLED, THAT
CREATES THE CONDITIONS FOR
THIS UPSET WITHIN THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY?
>> THE HEAD OF THIS NETWORK
ROGER AILES HAS BRILLIANTLY
SAID THAT IF YOU SEE
YOURSELF AS A VICTIM, THEN
YOU WILL BECOME A VICTIM,
BUT IF YOU SEE YOURSELF AS A
WINNER, THEN YOU WILL
EVENTUALLY WIN.
>> KEEP A DREAM JOURNAL,
FOLKS.
(LAUGHTER)
A VICTIM MENTALITY IS
WHAT IS CAUSING THIS.
A VICTIM MENTALITY.
A GENTLEMAN ON FOX.
A GENTLEMAN ON FOX NEWS SAID
THAT BLACK PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
CONVINCED BY A NETWORK OF
SHREWD PROPAGANDISTS THAT
THEY ARE SOMEHOW VICTIMS.
AND THAT IS WRONG TO AGITATE
A POPULATION, TO SCARE THEM,
UTILIZING ALL THE TOOLS OF
MODERN COMMUNICATIONS,
GRAPHICS, MUSIC, ET CETERA.
TO STOKE THESE PEOPLE INTO A
RESENTFUL FRENZY.
FOX NEWS FEELS THAT'S JUST
DAMAGING TO THIS GREAT
NATION AND TEARS AT
OUR VERY FABRIC.
I CAN'T IMAGINE ANYONE WOULD
DO SUCH A THING AT --
JUST ROLL THE [BLEEP] TAPE.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS SELLING
CLASS WARFARE.
>> IS THERE A GROWING
ANTI-WHITE PEOPLE MOVEMENT
IN AMERICA?
>> THE FEDS AND MANY STATE
GOVERNMENTS ARE WORKING HARD
TO TAKE THAT WAY YOUR GUNS.
>> MEANWHILE THEY WILL TAKE
YOUR MONEY.
>> THE INVASION OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
>> WE HAVE TERRORISTS
CROSSING THE MEXICAN BORDER.
>> SINGLED OUT FOR ITS
CHRISTIAN MESSAGE.
>> WE CAN PICK ON WHITE GUYS, WE
CAN PICK ON CHRISTIANS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> FOOD STAMP ABUSERS, FEEDING
ON TAXPAYERS.
>> THE UNITED STATES OF
ENTITLEMENT.
>> THEY'RE STEALING OUR
MONEY AND THE TAXPAYERS
SHOULD RISE UP.
>> WE ARE UNDER A TYRANNY
NOW.
>> ALL HAIL KING OBAMA.
>> AN IMPERIAL PRESIDENT.
>> AMERICA'S FREEDOM IS SLIPPING
AWAY.
>> AMERICA'S BEST DAYS ARE
BEHIND HER.
>> AMERICA YOU HAVE A
CHOICE TO MAKE.
>> IT IS TIME THAT WE TAKE OUR
COUNTRY BACK.
>> YOU NEED TO GET ANGRY.
OUR WORST FEARS MIGHT VERY
WELL BE HERE.
>> HOLY [BLEEP].
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW IF I'M SUPPOSED
TO OVERTHROW THE
GOVERNMENT OR GET ONE OF
THEM PANIC ROOMS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO.
BUT EITHER WAY, I'M JUST
HAPPY TO NOT BE INCITED.
IT ALMOST MAKES YOU THINK
THAT THE CRIME THAT THEY'RE
REALLY UP SET ABOUT OVER
THERE ISN'T RACE PIMPING OR
RACE ARSON, IT'S RACE
PLAGIARISM.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.